[Music]
three two one action hey guys welcome
back to off the record where we talk
about whatever we want and we got Meg
back back thanks for having me know I'm
so excited you texted me yeah man I love
it this off the record is sponsored by
native whoo
native creates safe simple effective
products that people use in the bathroom
every single day natives Deora is
formulated with FAL aluminum parabens
and tout it's filled with ingredients
found in nature such as coconut oil shea
butter and tapioca starch and it's never
tested on animals making the switch to
aluminum free deodorant does not mean
having to sacrifice our product
performance
people love native you do they have over
eight thousand five star reviews a lot
native comes in a wide variety of scents
for men and women plus they release new
limited edition seasonal sense
throughout the year they also offer an
unscented formula and baking sort of
free formula for those with
sensitivities their classic deodorant
cents include coconut and vanilla which
is the most popular lavender and rose to
comfort and mint and eucalyptus and mint
especially if you're a koala there is no
risk to try they offer free returns and
exchanges in the USA for 20% off the
first purchase visit native dealer calm
and use promo code OTR during checkout
this is our bottle will mine
specifically like it it's organic he
says he uses it in his thigh pit I don't
like this here try it smell it it smells
really good is it unused type it used it
oh yeah the bad smell get those are the
miscue because you have that like when
you transition from aluminum to not
aluminum did you have the I didn't know
the difference ition no this is a lot
better for you the transition what is
the luminol do you don't even know well
the lumen M is provides the
antiperspirant I believe but it's not
good for you I had no idea but I just
know that that smells amazing that's not
really good I like that and I can't wait
for these for them to send me but don't
worry
it for 20% off your first purchase visit
native deodorant calm and use promo code
OTR during checkout thank you very much
you very much e rub this on your body
parts yeah definitely there I'm just
making my camera to Sitges I'm making my
matcha green tea from sip the ceremonial
one I put the sugar in there it was you
put a salad in there what happened
umm I spilled it because half of it is
frozen it's are really like cold drink
so I have to freeze a drink and freeze
the ice sometimes hydra-matic ice gets
warm does that ruin the nutrients and
benefits of the matcha tea
oh it's many questions no answers no
more we're done here alright it doesn't
talk to your PR representative get back
to me thank you welcome back welcome
back meg on Instagram I'm like damn just
goes so strong I like your hair color
thank you so much is that your natural
hair color well you can see my roots
already my hairdresser just had a baby
so it's like about that time oh really
so what you gonna tell her it come back
I'm like yo ya know some natural
radicals Brown yeah I think it's just
like dishwater brown dishwater yeah but
he used to be strawberry blonde when I
was a baby so that's what I tell people
I see but it gets dark right cuz it
looks natural for you like I think it
fits with my yeah I think your best has
been the red good hair because I my hair
used to be black blond
Wow Brown I thought that was your
natural hair color yeah looks really
gonna fold you lose you can't you can't
trust them sometimes blondes have dark
eyebrows yeah that's true
yeah I never know if I always disclose
too much information so when people say
I like your hair I'm like thanks it's
fake
like it's not my real oh my god and then
you proceeded to start taking it out
just take off my wig like thanks do you
want to wear well bewell like oh I like
your shirt I'm like thanks I got it on
sale for $12 at Target you can go get it
that's me when you guys said we like my
skirt I was like it's from Hollister so
don't
hey you gotta show them is really cute
why do you think that happen do you get
ahead of it so no one can talk [ __ ] Oh
cuz we did talk [ __ ] already so she was
kind of like coming in like okay I
watched the video you guys talk [ __ ]
about Hollister please don't judge me
that's why she's coming I will say
precaution like something from Hollister
so I would understand you saying that
also when you're like in the punk rock
scene when you're in high school and
anything that made it to Hollister now
it's the prep now the prep zone it now
you can't use it so like leopard print
is pretty punk rock but then like now
you're like oh the preps are getting the
hold of it yeah yeah you gotta go back
to tie-dye or whatever is it like cuz
you're trying to surprise people because
you're trying to get people to go oh my
god you got it for that cheap I thought
you got it for like five hundred dollars
well you talked about when she says yeah
yeah it's like they compliment me
meaning it looks good and I want them to
know that it's actually cheese it's
cheap and they can afford it - yeah it's
not it's also I feel like that's my way
of friendship like when people share
deals with me when they're like oh girl
two for one right now if you go to a
sauce or what something like that I'm
like oh [ __ ] I'm gonna get it but yeah
what like when people don't want to
share their secrets we're all never
share anything that you keep that and
they're like oh it's a private dealer or
whatever I'm like damn your uncle oh I
forgot I forgot where I got bad
influence or good influence people buy
stuff from you not from her cuz you
don't want people to have the same thing
that you know I don't none of my
especially my friends no one could dress
like me I want none of that I just don't
want them to know that I have a dick but
they go or as you get that watch
I haven't tell you cuz it's a fake watch
yeah a lot of times people will think
I'm doing uh prandial on my channel cuz
in my videos I just get excited about
something I just bought and then I'm
like by the way not sponsored but I'd
say all the talking points I'm like Anna
can do this and this and this and did
you know it's on sale right now
and you could put a promo code in yeah
just this morning your ass you're like
well your hair looks great on Michael
make like roses you shampoo me I'm like
yeah it's sponsored but no I really
[ __ ] love it but that's actually
sponsored I get no money for the I
recommend y'all doing it wrong you know
what you need to do is have Amazon
affiliate links put that [ __ ] in your
description I know it's not that much I
got like 12 bucks though target I was
talking about
you could almost afford this skirt from
the hottest oh how much was that again
30 buddy what do you care I just want to
know that I could afford it I mean I'm
not gonna get it yeah but he could if he
wanted to okay my man I didn't mean it
[ __ ] piss on your parade yeah would
you you know have you guys have dressed
in dresses before in suppers it's
comfortable in my clothes yes yeah I'm
even a your bikini give you like wearing
a dress no I like my thighs touching and
it gets wet like even when I sleep I
have to get a pillow or a blanket and
put it to my thighs has a big touch they
start sweating does it feel good fits in
my shoes that asian mom muumuu that that
should see I could never dress like
yugioh I don't have a man body yeah
buddy
most coffee geo hard body qualms hard
bodies hard body means I have in your
beautiful heaven
I only say it cuz I'm jealous even blah
oh my god this episode oh my god I'm
gonna like recommend this to all my
friends Nicki never ever ever ever ever
tells me anything nice did everyone hear
that in this room Casey did you hear it
off camera
yeah she's built up I could tear her
back down later so what you've been up
to these days I'm working I'm boring
what's what's what's your line of well
what's work for you
okay swatting yes yeah I do a lot of
squatting a lot of lifting
I have a program called stronger by the
day so help people get stronger by the
day by the day I'll take it I need to
get stronger
it's a nutrition course because people
always ask me about the nutrition side
of things and for so long I didn't have
anything so I've been building a course
and I'm really excited because I was
like oh I was trying to figure out how
to how much to price it cuz I spent a
lot of time a lot of money investing and
everything but I decided I make it real
cheap for good yes so hard to do what
was it that took the most amount of time
well I wrote the entire course and so
the idea was to make it kind of like
help people in in are in like the
powerlifting side you get a lot of
people will go straight to counting
macros this really complex like
confusing thing and so I wanted to break
it down so I feel like okay you should
start with like drinking more water and
like very basic like the vast room that
you want to think about to really assess
your Diner chip because people don't
even like drink water or walk around the
block yeah I married one of those people
you don't drink water maybe they should
think I remember like when I started
like I was powerlifting for like six
months and then during that time I was
also tracking macros but it seemed like
really confusing scary thing I did have
it can take a beer in life too yeah
you're always thinking like how much is
in this and I would count on your phone
guy really weird I'm just lard that's
crazy that's not normal - it's okay
that's barks method it can that's crazy
you're right some people can really like
thrive off of that but mostly I don't
need you don't need to do no one needs
to do that to be healthy we really say
that depends on your goal if you're
trying to be healthy you don't need to
but then if you have specific I want to
weigh this much or look this much in you
sometimes you can get triggered by
having to count everything like if you
used to have an eating disorder you get
obsessed with like numbers and that kind
of stuff and then like that kind of
triggers that but but I I think yeah for
you what you do like bodybuilding yeah I
don't know anything about that so it
probably helps you people are looking at
me now no have you ever thought so
you're selling this program is it like
um is it like an e-book that people can
download or so um a new it's a course
video course yeah
so it has videos of me explaining all
the content so like there's nothing
[ __ ] boring to shoot oh my gosh yes
well it's all scripted too so I'm like
how courses are so hard to do I got a
couple of but luckily when I film I
usually do scripted for my youtube
channel I do scripted and I have my
fiancee it'll be back there he's like my
business partner as well and he'll give
me some banter like he'll make usually
he makes fun of me like it to break up
the monotony of me talking about
something so that's a good like comedic
break cuz then I'll go on a riff and
like tell a specific you'll include his
voice in the cut off because it's kind
of like yeah trailing off in a distance
voice exactly oh cool it's a fun it's a
fun way to do it have you ever thought
about because you're Sepp taking him
tell them I can't talk anymore
so you're the compliments are all I know
is even messing it this way don't
compliment people like you were talking
about pricing your thing and making it
really affordable for everybody have you
ever thought about doing like an app
version where like you can kind of
charge for a subscription and then you
have like different meal plans every
month or something like that that people
are like oh I want something different
cuz I get bored with my food yeah so
this we knew it was only going to be
like an eight week thing to kind of
cover the basics of everything but we
have that's like exactly what we do for
our training program oh say but
nutrition I want to I wanted to try to
give so much information in an organized
like step-by-step way so every week they
go through a lesson and then they have a
task so it's like this week's task is
two for three days out of the week keep
a diet record or like a Nutrition
Journal and like log everything
not that you have to do everyday but
it's just like a little step to like
build awareness I'm so good habits do
exactly the whole basis of it is to
build good habits so I didn't want
people to like constantly be like focus
on their nutrition so much so I wanted
to try to like lay the baseline first
and then maybe down the line will do
something like develop good habits yeah
did you do personal training before yeah
never had people like you like I wanna
[ __ ] lose 200 pounds in one week and
you're like [ __ ] I can't do [ __ ]
magic like expect for me I mean I think
you'd a good personal trainer is someone
who can set realistic expectations and
also educate their client as much as
possible I personally haven't worked
with too many people with obesity
because that's like a more I would like
to say that's something that not that it
requires a specialist but I think it
requires someone who is used to working
with clients like that so it's different
from like people that just wanna be F
like dirty like working out and they
want to get even better like an athlete
athletics ISM or whatever yeah that's
like most of your clients where they're
like in sports or something I would say
a lot of more serious like intermediate
lifters like maybe they follow like K
lights enos or they I did her program
yeah like something like that where
maybe you have some bodyweight workouts
or something like that
the person coming to me usually is
pretty familiar with the gym they've
lifted before and they want to or maybe
they're really interested in doing that
so they're a little like a step up from
that's true because when people hear
personal trainer they don't know the
difference between someone at you know
like a commercial gym or training you or
it's like a special like specific coach
for something that you're doing and the
regular world you know and when you hear
that it's like oh well what are you
gonna help me do lose weight get buff
that I think that'll be the main
question in a lot of normal people's
heads at least that's what my first
question would be is like are gonna help
me lose weight are you gonna help me get
buff it be cool if they made an app that
was like pimp my body
and then you take a picture of them and
then you got like this eye padding but
you can look like this the bodybuilding
version yes every week or every day if
you ate this exact thing then you could
choose your body style and then you're
like you want to have big legs but tiny
arms you could do this you just do all
these different all of us that's cool I
wonder if it amazed done that before it
seems like I have all like functional
pace the [ __ ] out of me if I knew what I
would look like based off of what I was
doing yeah cuz some people don't even
care about how they look like but like
let's say you go this is you right now
and this guy barely can jump a foot high
and then you go but this one you can be
in this guy Duncan like crazy or not
mops like this it is so so unrealistic
expertise what's that thing Oh like you
make a deep fake of them like claims
like over LeBron James oh yeah it's like
a white fat guy and their fat LeBron
James P yeah you can do that sick
actually you could charge a lot for that
costs reminds me of I don't know if you
ever had this in the doctor's office
when you're a kid but like those things
work you can change the face but the
body stays the same we're like you could
change like the like there's like a
clown picture a girl picture or whatever
and then you could like make the clown
have a girl body you're like well make
the girl have a clown say or whatever I
have like amazing washes just buff arms
but not both legs this it's past the
joke has to work you know just move on
move on no I love your approach because
you're like very approachable and you're
very like like the way you look at fit
this is from like a very common person's
like level like you clearly know what
you're talking about but because you
know it's so well you break it down
where it's like not so intimidating yeah
and I think a lot of people come to me
or follow my page over some other
fitness influencers because it is a
slightly different approach because I'm
like oh [ __ ] looking at how your body
can look it's rather like how can you
perform and
let's do let's do something badass like
let's make you forget how you look let's
get you doing some badass stuff yeah
yeah squat your times body weight or
something yeah and I think that can be
inspiring especially to people who have
struggled with like wanting to look a
certain way and they're just over that
how much you squat the other day I
squatted 265 pounds but my best ever
it's like 308 whoa that was like a year
ago today this weekend because it's
nationalist this weekend you compete a
national disaster yeah mm-hmm how come
we didn't do it this year because a
businesswoman now yeah I've been working
what's the biggest thing that's asked
like like I want a nice ass can you
teach me how to do that or like is it
more like I want to lift a [ __ ] ton like
gonna beat up my boyfriend my boyfriend
in the face it always comes back to
domestic abuse yeah pretty cool that's
their love language I chucked my I
chucked my husband my frickin fingers
were too small it's time I want a bigger
finger just shut them up they're just in
there like this yeah how do I get bigger
fingers most most people want to get
strong mmm because I think most people
come to me they're sick of everything
else
look I've been skinny I've been this
I've been red okay but it feels good to
know that like at any time when you I
didn't want you had attracted me to
powerlifting is I know once I attained
cause people think of strength as more
of like how much power you have but as
as much skill acquisition as it is
gaining power so it's cool to know that
the minute I open my eyes if I need to
apply 600 pounds of force onto something
I can give you that 24 hours a day and
that's what really attracted me to
powerlifting is like you've literally
become a completely different animal I
picture a client coming up to her like
you know what if my if my husband is
like changing the [ __ ] oil and the
car slams up I want to be able to pick
that [ __ ] up and throw it can
you help me do that you know doesn't the
realistic expert - yeah
in the biggest the most like the one of
the more dangerous like everyday things
that can happen to people as they age is
they fall down their balance and a lot
of that does have to do is not having
enough strength and then they fall down
and they can't get themselves back up so
look like bones - yeah and your bone
density to osteoporosis especially for
women I mean I know this is like when
you're aging a little bit older but if
you can get your bone density higher
before you start losing your muscle mass
you got a train girl 50 weights yeah
lift that weight your muscle is anytime
you contract a muscle you're pulling
against your bone and so you're making
your bones Ari's we're probably it's
probably already deteriorating right no
no it's never too late
I mean grandmas cured osteoporosis from
squatting 70 going like it's already
going you could just like delay the
amount I think it's you don't use it you
lose it that's true
[Music]